The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
Yes.
Let's have an on time departure.
The topic of last class
was the ac Stark effect.
And I said what I've
been saying to you,
was additional [INAUDIBLE]
of the ac Stark difference
from perturbation theory.
But then I have three
points for discussion.
The first one was [INAUDIBLE]
for the [INAUDIBLE] problem,
[INAUDIBLE].
The second one was the
oscillator strength,
which we almost finished.
And today, I want to say a
few words about [INAUDIBLE]
in [INAUDIBLE].
And eventually how
the ac Stark effect
leads to the absorption
coefficient, which many of you
use [INAUDIBLE].
So I mentioned that the
oscillator strength is actually
one way to parametrize
the matrix element.
We'll actually talk
most of the lecture
today about matrix
element, but I
come to that in a few minutes.
From here, the matrix
element is nothing,
but you get on with [INAUDIBLE].
Sure, it's a dimension
of the Bohr radius
but we don't really think
in terms of lengths.
There are two ways how you
want to use a matrix element.
One is the matrix
elements squared,
having some other
effect with which
to [INAUDIBLE] this
likeness, an actual likeness
against a number you should
know how to [INAUDIBLE].
Or another way to
parametrize matrix elements
is by this [INAUDIBLE]
number, which
is what we will
see in this class.
And that's, of
course, also related
to semi-classical physics.
And I mentioned that
in the last class,
that the oscillator
strength allows
us to connect the quantum
mechanical treatment of an atom
to the response of a
classical harmonic oscillator
through the charge of
an external [INAUDIBLE].
So I used this expression,
it was the end of class last.
I used this expression
for the matrix element
in terms of the
oscillator strengths
to give you a nice relationship
for strong transition
as in the alkaline E lines,
where the oscillator strength
is close to 1.
You see that the
matrix element is
1 over square of 2
times the geometric mean
of the complete wave
lengths of the electron,
and the wave lengths
of the transition.
So that's actually important
for the dipole approximation,
because the concurrent wave
lengths of the electron
is very, very small.
So therefore if
the matrix element
is the geometric
mean of the two,
that means that
the matrix element
is smaller than the
optical wave lengths.
And therefore,
the matrix element
is the length scale,
the relevant length
scale of the atom
for transition.
It is smaller than the
optical wave lengths.
And that means-- and we'll
talk about it today--
that in the expression E to
the IKR, KR is really small.
So we can do the
dipole approximation.
Now I have a question for you.
I did it, frankly,
because we don't
have many questions
to discuss with.
But I mentioned that there is
a sum rule for the oscillator
strengths.
And the sum rule limits it to 1.
And if there's a really
strong transition,
it kind of exhausts
the sum rule,
and this is what I
was talking about.
But because the thought crossed
my mind after last lecture,
if I don't add
something to it, you
may actually use it as a
proof, which would be wrong.
That the matrix element cannot
be larger than what you see
on the right hand side.
On the other hand, we discussed
in the context of Rydberg atoms
that Rydberg atoms can
have huge matrix elements.
Matrix elements
which [INAUDIBLE]
but they can really become huge.
So how do you reconcile
the fact that Rydberg atoms
in large instates, in
states with large strengths
of [INAUDIBLE] numbers can
have huge matrix elements.
How do you reconcile
it with our discussion
of oscillator strengths
and sum rules?
The answer is simple but subtle.
So is it a proof that the
matrix elements are impossible?
Or if big matrix elements,
huge matrix elements,
are possible, what property
of the oscillator strengths
did I not emphasize?
I mean, keep watching.
So first, are there atoms which
have huge matrix elements?
Yes.
Rydberg atoms.
So the left hand side
can be really huge.
On the right hand side,
we have the wave lengths
of the transition
which can get large.
You have to count
the wave lengths.
But then you have the
oscillator strengths.
And the oscillator
strengths, the sum
of all oscillator
strengths is 1.
But you have to be careful
that not all oscillator
strengths have to be possible.
The definition of the
oscillator strengths
involves frequency from
one state to the next.
And depending whether
you go up or down,
the frequency has
positive or negative side.
So therefore we have a sum rule.
For the ground state,
all frequencies
are positive because
you can only go up.
So therefore the
sum rule is only
very useful for
the ground state,
because all oscillator
strengths are positive.
And if one oscillator
strength is 1,
you know no other transition
has any strength at all.
However when you
have an excited state
and you find an oscillator
strength which is 1,
you could still have a lot
of other strong transitions,
but their oscillator strengths
are positive and negative
and they compensate for
each other in the sum rule.
So just be careful about that.
For the ground state-- and
this is what I've proven to you
here, I think
fairly rigorously--
if you are in the ground state,
the transition matrix element
cannot be larger than
the geometric mean
of the [INAUDIBLE] wave lengths
and the [INAUDIBLE] wave
lengths.
But for excited states,
you have to be careful,
because the oscillator
strengths can have cosines.
OK.
Any questions about that?
Then let's talk quickly
about the third point
I wanted to discuss.
And this is the relationship
to the index of refraction.
The polarizability here is
responsible for the index
of refraction.
Well, the polarizability
determines [INAUDIBLE]
evaluate the constant and use
whatever relation you want,
but for a common
physics purpose,
this is sort of the
useful relation.
This is the index of refraction.
It's related to
the polarizability.
And assuming that the
polarizability is small,
you get this, the
parallel extension.
So roughly saying n minus 1.
The difference of the index
of refraction from the vacuum
is proportionate to
the atomic density
times the polarizability.
OK.
And we know this is what we
derive from the perturbation
theory, that the
polarizability depends
on a matrix element squared
and 1 over the cube.
Now I want to sort of show you
that by just using that concept
and putting in
phenomenologically dissipation,
we can get a full expression
what happens to a laser
beam crossing an atomic medium,
like a [INAUDIBLE] condensate.
How much of the laser
beam is absorbed?
And what is the feature
of the laser beam.
In order to get interesting
or simple formula,
I want to now parametrize
the matrix element
by this correlated gamma.
This will turn out with
an actual [INAUDIBLE],
but right now, since
we haven't talked
about spontaneous
emission, just say
I replace the matrix
element by gamma.
And then I can write
the index of refraction
in the following way.
But the matrix element squared
is now parametrized by gamma.
I have also introduced
the coordinate sigma
0, which will later be
the lesson in absorption
for section for atoms.
But again here, just use
it as a parametrization.
I mean, I've not introduced
any new concepts.
I've just rewritten this
expression in this way,
involved sigma 0, which is a
cross-section, and gamma, which
is an actual light.
OK.
The polarizability depended--
that was perturbation
theory-- 1 over the
energy denominator,
or 1 over the [INAUDIBLE].
Now we have used, with
the oscillator strengths,
the analogy to a classical
harmonic oscillator.
And at some level, you know
that every harmonic oscillator
must have little bit of damping.
And so the same applies
to atomic oscillators.
And if you can account
for the damping
by putting into the frequency
denominator of the [INAUDIBLE],
1 over delta.
Give it an imaginary part.
So I'm just telling
you here, yes.
Every oscillator
has some damping,
and I can phenomenologically
accounting for the damping
by making the resonant
frequency, or the tuning,
slightly complex by
adding imaginary part.
Later on I want to express
all the tunings normalized
to this line which is parallel
to a normalized [INAUDIBLE]
imaginary part.
OK.
So we have the situation
that this expression, gamma
over delta-- this
was the expression
for the polarizability--
now acquires
a small imaginary part, and that
means it's a complex number.
And I can now take this
expression separate it
into an imaginary
part and a real part.
So why do I do that?
Well, the index of
refraction appears
in the propagation
of the plane wave.
If you're a plane
wave, the key vector
is no longer the key
vector in vacuum.
It's multiplied with
the index of refraction,
and that's what I do here.
And now you see
that immediately,
an imaginary part of
the index of refraction
leads to absorption.
And the real part
leads to [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So what we have now is we have
this expression for the plane
wave after it is propagated
through the medium.
And we see there is
exponential absorption.
Exponential absorption.
On resonance, we have
an optimal density
which is given by
this expression.
And the second term here
give us a phase shift.
And it's clear since we
have one medium which
has a certain thickness that the
optical density and the phase
shift are related.
Yes.
If you're on resonance, you
have the maximum optical density
and the maximum absorption.
And the optical
density, of course,
is 1 over the
[INAUDIBLE] squared.
[INAUDIBLE]
Whereas for large detuning,
the phase shift goes as 1
over delta.
It's the dispersive
scaling with the tuning,
and this is also what we
had when we started out.
When we would have started out
with the polarizability and not
a decaying dissipation, because
far away from resonance,
you simply have a regional
of dispersive effect,
and dissipation doesn't occur.
So anyway, I
thought I would just
show that to you because this
is a full understanding of what
happens to optical views
when they pass the atomic
[INAUDIBLE].
It's nothing else than
the polarizability
or the harmonic
oscillator response
of an atom to
electromagnetic radiation.
The only thing which is
non-derivative here is--
and that's what we will
discuss later in this course--
is in order to get the
final result, which
you may want to use in
analyzing your data,
you have to set the
dissipative, the damping
of the harmonic oscillator,
equal with this gamma
parameter.
And that's something I cannot
tell you without talking about
spontaneous emission.
So just to remind you, I
introduce big gamma just
as a parametrization
of the matrix element.
Then I introduce
phenomenologically little gamma
as just the damping of
the harmonic oscillator
of those two quantities
for two levels [INAUDIBLE]
are identical.
And that's something I
cannot show you here,
because this requires discussion
of spontaneous emission
and the other modes of
the electromagnetic field.
This is not covered by
a discussion of the ac
polarizability.
OK.
Any questions?
But still-- I know
I'm repeating myself--
I always find it interesting
that the whole physics
of absorption, the
beams are absorbed,
you can pretty much pull
it out of the response
of a harmonic oscillator.
It's only the damping rate
of the harmonic oscillator
that this is simply
spontaneous emission.
That's the only
point where you have
to go beyond the ac Stark shift
and bring in the [INAUDIBLE]
nature of the
electromagnetic field
and all the empty
modes of the vacuum.
Any questions about waves,
or in general interactions
of atoms with electric
and magnetic fields?
Well, then let's move on.
We have talked about
electric and magnetic fields
intimately for
very good reasons,
because low frequency fields
are either electric or magnetic
in nature.
But ultimately, we
want to understand
what happens when atoms
interact with light.
And this is our
discussion for today.
The outline of this
chapter is as follows.
Today, all I want to discuss is
the coupling matrix in an atom.
In other words, when we have
a Hamiltonian between state A
and B, we have an
off-diagonal matrix element.
And this off-diagonal matrix
element causes transitions.
Or when we calculate it, the
effect of electric field--
the ec Stark effect or
the ac Stark effect,
we assume there was a
quantity, state 1, state 2,
and we put some
operator in between.
So this was a matrix element
which connects the two states.
And so far, we
have always assumed
using the classical
multiple expansion
of electromagnetic field energy
that this matrix element has
the form electric field
times dipole matrix element.
And therefore, the
relevant matrix element
was the position operator of
the electron connecting the two
states.
So in a way, we have
used it all the time.
But in any more advanced
discussion of atomic physics,
you have two states.
And as long as they
are coupled, you
have something
which you call H1 2
or you call it
matrix element N1 2,
and you're not even asking
where it comes from.
When two levels are coupled,
they undergo Rabi oscillations.
You have transitions.
If you're in the excited state
and you have a matrix element,
you get spontaneous emission.
So a lot of the things
we want to discuss
about atomic physics,
all they require
a number which is a matrix
element between state
1 and state 2.
And today, I want to talk to
you about different mechanisms
which can lead to
matrix element.
We talked about the
dipole operator,
but you also talk about
higher order possibilities,
magnetic dipole coupling, or
electric [INAUDIBLE] coupling.
And a little bit later--
this is an outlook--
we will talk about
twofold uncoupling.
But in the end, even if
it's a twofold uncoupling,
for a lot or phenomena,
all you need is a coupling.
A coupling means
a Rabi frequency.
A Rabi frequency means Rabi
oscillation, and so on.
So today the focus is,
what is the structure, what
are the principles
behind this number, which
is a relevant matrix element.
OK.
So that's today.
Next week is spring
break, but when we resume,
we then want to talk about what
is the matrix element doing?
And there are two cases
which we have to consider.
One is we can see it's
narrow band and broad band.
This matrix element
can couple just
to one move of the
electromagnetic field.
Everything is coherent.
We have coherent
Rabi oscillation.
Or you can couple to
many modes, and then you
have a broad band situation,
which may be described
[INAUDIBLE] and this
[INAUDIBLE] unit.
Very, very different behavior.
So that's what we
then want to discuss.
When atoms interact
with light, we
have two very different
limiting cases, narrow band
and broad band.
And eventually, we want to
go beyond the semi-classical
formulation of the
electromagnetic field
and we'll talk about the
quantized electromagnetic
field.
OK.
So let's talk about the
coupling between atoms
and electromagnetic fields.
I want to give you
very brief derivation
of the canonical coupling
between electromagnetic fields
and atoms.
I know this is covered
in many textbooks,
and we have a very
deep discussion
about it using the full
QED formulas in A422,
but I feel this
course A421 would not
be complete without a
discussion like that.
And secondly-- this
is so important
if you hear it twice from
two different angles, that's
probably useful-- I
just want to remind you
that if you use classical
electromagnetism
and the Lagrangian
formalism, you find the very
elegant result that the coupling
to the electromagnetic field
can be introduced by
modifying the momentum.
That the canonical momentum
which appears in the Lagrangian
equation is no longer
the mechanical momentum
which gives rise to
kinetic energy, But?
It is modified by
the vector potential.
So therefore the
Hamiltonian-- at this point
it's the classical
Hamiltonian, but then we
use the same expression
in quantum mechanics.
The Hamiltonian has kinetic
energy and potential energy.
But the kinetic energy
is no longer p square.
Because by p, I mean now
the canonical momentum.
We have to correct for
the vector potential
to go from the
canonical momentum
to the mechanical momentum.
And if we squared it, this
gives the kinetic energy.
If you worry about
this sign here,
I will assume now that
the electron has a charge.
The charge q f the
electron was minus e,
so that's why we have a plus
sign here and not a minus sign.
OK.
So we will use this fact that we
have to substitute the momentum
operator by the
canonical momentum, which
is no longer the
mechanical momentum.
We used it also in our
quantum mechanical Hamiltonian
in the Schrodinger equation.
If you ask me, can you prove it?
No.
Nobody can prove it.
We can never prove what a
quantum mechanical equation is.
We can just use
physical understanding,
physical analogies.
And that's how quantum mechanics
was developed in [INAUDIBLE].
Based on the classic quantum
mechanical correspondence,
this seems to be a very
reasonable assumption.
And ultimately, this very
reasonable assumption
has now withstood the test of
time for many, many decades,
over almost 100 years.
So that's why we assume that
doing the same substitution
in the Schrodinger equation
for the momentum operator
gives the right result,
but there is no way
how you can rigorously
derive fundamental equations
in physics.
You can observe
nature, postulate them,
and verify them.
So therefore, this line, which
was the classical Hamiltonian,
by interpreting
p as an operator,
is now our quantum
mechanical Hamiltonian.
And the one thing we
have to consider now
is that once we have
quantum mechanical operator,
we have to be careful
about compute order.
That certain quantities
have to be ordered.
It matters which
one we put first.
What is convenient now is
to use the Coulomb gauge.
In the Coulomb gauge,
diversions of A is zero.
But the del operator, the
deliberative operator,
is the operator of the
canonical momentum.
And therefore, if you
use the Coulomb gauge,
then we have commutativity
between the canonical momentum,
p, and the vector potential.
And that's sort of nice,
because if you take this square
and square it out, we
get p dot A plus A dot p,
but they are the same
in the Coulomb gauge.
So therefore our Hamiltonian
has now the following terms.
We call it H naught.
And we assume that the Coulomb
potential of the nucleus,
which eventually gets
the electronic structure
of the atom, is included here.
So this is the
Hamiltonian part which
describes the
structure of atoms.
And then we have two
terms which couple
to the electromagnetic field.
So this is p dot A or A dot p.
It doesn't matter in
the Coulomb gauge.
We call this the
interaction Hamiltonian.
And now we get a
second order term,
which is the A square term.
Well, since it's second
order, we designate it.
We use the symbol H2.
In the following, we neglect
the second order term.
The argument is for weak fields.
It doesn't matter.
It's not so important
because it's higher order.
However, in A422, we
look at it more carefully
and we can actually do a
canonical transformation which
eliminates the A square term.
So to drop it is not necessary.
You can actually show with
a canonical transformation
that I'm doing is actually
more exact than just
saying small and delineated.
But anyway, I don't want to
spend too much time on it.
All I wanted to remind you, what
are the steps to obtain-- just
give me one second-- to obtain
the interaction Hamiltonian,
and that's what I want
to use for the remainder
of this class.
That we have the
coupling of momentum
to the vector potential.
We assume that the vector
potential-- we are not
quantizing the
electromagnetic field.
It's a semi-classical field.
It's therefore a
classical vector.
And we will
investigate what is now
the coupling between an
atom for this Hamiltonian
to a plane wave of the
electromagnetic field.
So therefore we are introducing
for the vector potential
the expression that the vector
potential has an Hamiltonian
naught.
The polarization p hat, and
then the plane wave factor
e to the ikr minus i omega t.
So this can be divided in
a much more rigorous way,
but this is now the starting
point of our discussion.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
Any questions about that?
Yes.
Matt.
AUDIENCE: Is it a
little bit weird
that you're going to take the
divergence of its particular A
that's not 0?
Since it's divergence of e to
the ik dot r, just k dot A?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
You said the divergence
of A-- so you're
asking what is the
divergence of A,
if A is a plane
wave e to the ikr?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
propagation of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What happens is,
the polarization is
A, and if you take the
divergence of the plane wave,
you get a K vector, so you get
this [INAUDIBLE] product of e
dot k.
And electromagnetic
waves propagate.
The polarizations
[INAUDIBLE] propagation.
So ultimately what you
find is with Coulomb gauge
and the radiation
field is transverse.
It is only polarization
[INAUDIBLE] propagation.
OK.
So we want to talk
about matrix element.
So the matrix element
between two states.
Du to the interaction
Hamiltonian for one plane wave
has the e to the minus i omega
t dependence, which is trivial.
I mean, in terms
of we will assume
that there is a
monochromatic wave.
And what you want
to discuss now is
this time independent
factor, H ba.
Let me get the factors.
Let me get the polarization.
So your relevant operator which
connects the two states A and B
is the momentum operator.
And now for the
plane wave, we want
to do an expansion
in orders of kr.
And the leading term will
be the dipole approximation
and the next order
term will give rise
to magnetic dipole and electric
quadrupole transitions.
So first, the fact that
I can do this expansion
requires that k dot A
is much smaller than 1.
So it's a long wave
length approximation,
which you can say is valid as
long as the atom is smaller
than the wave length
we are talking about.
And I will show you later when
I discuss the next higher order
term that for atoms
in the ground state,
this is actually also
an expansion alpha.
So again we retrieve the
fine-structure constant.
So when we do this expansion
of this plane wave exponential,
every term is smaller
than the previous term
by the fine-structure constant
alpha, which is 1 over 137.
OK.
So the leading term is
the 1, and this gives rise
to the dipole approximation.
So what I want to show
you now in one or two
minutes is that this is indeed
the dipole approximation.
It leads to a
matrix element which
is electric field times
r, the dipole moment.
What we have right now is A
dot p, the vector potential,
times the momentum.
So in other words,
I want to show you
that the A dot p matrix element
is equivalent to an e dot r
matrix element.
This can be done with a
canonical transformation, which
we'll do in A422, but here
let me sort of just show you
the elementary discussion.
We want to replace
the vector potential
by the electric field.
So therefore, we use the
fact that the electric field
is the derivative of
the vector potential.
And the derivative of
the vector potential
means since we have an E the
minus i omega t dependence,
that we simply multiply
with a factor of omega
of the frequency.
And what we obtain here
is then the amplitude
of the electric field, E naught.
So with that, we
have a matrix element
which now involves
the electric field.
But still the matrix element
of the momentum operator.
But we can easily go from
the momentum operator
to the position operator
by taking the fact
that the momentum
operator is nothing
else than the commutator of r
with the Hamiltonian H naught.
The kinetic energy in
H naught is p square,
and the commutator of r
with p square is simply p.
So this is what I'm using here.
And these are the p factors.
So therefore if you take the
momentum operator between two
states, we have this relation
between the momentum operator
and the position operator.
But we have not the
momentum operator.
We have the commutator.
And r H naught gives us r.
But when H naught acts on the
a, it gives the energy in a.
For the other part of
the commutator, which
is H naught r, we can have H
naught act on the left hand
side on b, and this
gives us the energy ab.
For dividing by H
bar, what we get
is the energy
difference, eb minus ea.
Or in frequency units, omega ba.
So this is now how we have
implemented the commutator.
So that by inserting
this into this equation,
we now finally obtain our
result for the matrix element
in the dipole approximation.
We have e, the electric field
amplitude, the polarization,
the matrix element
b r a, omega ba,
and here we have an 1 over
omega in the denominator, which
came from the derivative of
the vector potential da dt.
This here is the matrix
element of the dipole operator.
So in other words, I
have derived for you
that the interaction
matrix element
in the dipole approximation
is the dipole operator
times the electric field as
long as I make the approximation
that this frequency factor's
on the order of [INAUDIBLE].
Now this is clearly the
case in your resonance,
so you should be safe.
However, if you do the
more rigorous derivation
of the dipole Hamiltonian
using canonical transformation,
this factor of omega ba
over omega does not appear.
So again, the dipole
approximations
is better than I
presented today.
The two approximations
topping the A squared term
and approximating this
ratio of frequencies with 1
is not necessary if you
use the other methods using
canonical transformation.
Any questions about that?
Let me make one comment.
I've shown you in
this derivation
that the A dot p term,
the A dot p interaction
within the dipole approximation
is identical to the e dot r
interaction.
So these are the same operators,
and if you would exactly
calculate them in atomic
structure calculation,
you would get the same coupling,
the same matrix element.
However, in practice, there
are important differences.
Because the E dot r
operator, the r operator,
has a lot of weight
where the electron is
far away from the nucleus
because it's multiplied with r.
Whereas the p operator
emphasizes the derivative
of the wave function,
and this is usually
strong at close distances.
So in the end, the results
have to be the same.
But if you make an approximation
to your wave function,
one formulation may be
numerically much more accurate
than the other one.
But fundamentally, the
two terms are the same
and they are related the way
how I derived it for you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when we say it's
the dipole approximation,
does it mean that it's
a long wave length,
or be the small field
or everything together.
So what's the absolute
fundamental assumption of this?
PROFESSOR: The absolute
fundamental assumption
of the dipole
approximation is that we
assume-- let me just scroll up.
In the equation above,
we had an expression
for the vector potential.
And the dipole
approximation means
that we can neglect the position
dependence of the vector
potential A of r,
so we approximate A
of r as being A evaluated
at the origin of the atom.
And over the extent, over
the size of the atom,
we do not have to consider
a spacial dependence
of the vector potential.
So this is sufficient.
The other things that
e square is small
and that we're
near resonance-- I
have to make those
assumptions if I
want to use this
elementary derivation.
But with a canonical
transformation,
as is discussed in
atom-photon interactions,
you do not need those
additional assumptions.
The only assumption behind
the dipole approximation
is that one, and this means
that the extent of the atom
is much smaller than the
optical wave lengths.
OK.
But there are situations where
the leading approximation
vanishes.
For instance, if two levels
have the same parity,
then the dipole operator
between the two of them is 0.
And then if you want to
have a transition between,
or if you want to consider a
transition between those two
levels, it will come
from next order terms.
So let's now discuss higher
order radiation processes.
So the motivation why I want to
discuss higher order radiation
processes is because
in some basic courses,
you only need the
dipole approximation.
And you think the
dipole coupling
is the only coupling
which exists in the world.
And by going to
higher order, I want
to show you that
this is not the case.
Also I want to sort of
give you an idea what
it means if you
have leading order
transitions are forbidden.
I want to sort of show
you how other terms come
in which can couple two levels.
And also, actually, when
you drive transitions
within the hyper-fine structure
using radio frequency fields,
you are not driving them
with the electric dipole
approximation.
You're driving them
with a magnetic dipole,
and this is actually
the next approximation.
So there's a number
of reasons why
I want to show you what
the next order terms are,
and how they actually
lead to beautiful result,
magnetic dipole, and electric
quadrupole transitions.
So our coupling term-- let
me just rewrite the equation.
Let me now simplify the
notation by assuming
that the polarization
is in the z direction
and the propagation
is in the x direction.
So then the coupling
had the dipole term.
And the next order
term is ikx, and this
is what we want to
investigate now.
So the term kx or kr is smaller.
And now I want to
show you explicitly
that it's smaller by alpha.
The k vector of the photon is
related to the frequency H bar
omega divided by H bar z.
If I approximate for
r, the relevant r
when we indicate over
the wave function
will be the Bohr radius.
The relevant frequency, H bar
omega, well, it's a Rydberg.
And the Rydberg is e square
over the Bohr radius.
So now if I insert it, the
Bohr radius cancels out.
And what we find is,
well, kr is dimensionless.
We have to find something
which is dimensionless,
but expressed by the fundamental
constants of atomic physics.
And the only quantity which is
available for that-- it's not
a surprise-- is alpha.
The fine-structure constant.
So therefore the
dipole approximation
is actually the result of an
expansion of the plane wave
e the ikr factor in
units of expansion
in the fine-structure constant.
OK.
We want to look now
at the second term.
And well, sometimes if
you deal with a term,
we first make it
more complicated
and then we simplify it.
I want to sort of symmetrize
and anti-symmetrize it
in the following way.
This is p z x.
So let me subtract z p x.
But then, of course,
I have to add it.
So now we have two terms.
1 has a minus sign,
one has a plus sign.
And as will see
in just a minute,
is the first one is
magnetic dipole transition.
The second one is electric
quadrupole transition.
And we see that the first
one can be regarded as-- p
z x is like p dot r.
Its the y component of
the vector product and
is therefore the y component of
the orbital angular momentum.
OK.
So let's focus for
now on this part.
The second term, which is
the electric quadrupole term,
we'll do in a few moments.
The relevant matrix element
is now the matrix element
of the orbital
angular momentum Ly.
The p factor-- let
me just collect
all of the constant imaginary
unit ehr AK over 2 mc.
That looks complicated,
but it immediately
simplifies when we realize that
this here is the Bohr magneton.
And well, we still have
the vector potential.
But the magnetic field is the
curl of the vector potential,
and that means we will
assume that we have a vector
potential propagating
in x, polarized in z.
That means that our
magnetic field is that.
So therefore ka, which
appears in our expression
for the coupling, is
just the magnetic field.
So therefore we find the
result that the next order
term in the coupling
of the atoms
to the electromagnetic
field have the simple form
to the electromagnetic field.
That it is the
magnetic field part
of the electromagnetic wave
times the Bohr magneton
times the matrix element, due
to the orbital angular momentum
operator.
And actually, if you take
the orbital angular momentum
and multiply it with
the Bohr magneton,
this is actually the operator
of the magnetic moment.
Well, with a minus sign because
the electron is negative
charged.
Remember we had
introduced the operator
for the magnetic moment.
And the magnetic
moment was the g factor
times the Bohr magneton times
the orbital angular momentum.
And the g factor for
the orbital motion is 1.
So therefore the interaction
we are talking about
is the Bohr magneton
times the magnetic field.
And, of course, what we
realize is the operator-- maybe
I should back up for a second
and say what we actually
realize is that
operator which couples
to the electromagnetic field
has actually the form u dot b.
This is exactly what we use
for the Zeeman effect in a DC
magnetic field.
But now the same
form u dot b appears
for time dependent
magnetic field.
And time depending
magnetic fields
are not only creating
level shifts.
They can also use transitions
through the matrix element.
So in other words,
this whole exercise
show you that the form u dot
b, which appeared naturally
in the formulation
for DC magnetic field,
also applies to AC
magnetic fields.
But with that, I can
say, wait a moment.
There are now two sources
for the magnetic movement
of the atom.
One is due to orbital
angular momentum,
and the other one is due
to spin angular momentum.
But the spin
angular momentum has
a g factor, which is different.
The approximation of the
[INAUDIBLE] creation is 2.
So therefore I
mean, we will never
get spin out of a
semi-classical discussion.
Remember, we started with a
classical canonical treatment
of the electromagnetic
field, canonical momentum.
And now we are
running with it and we
find that there is a coupling
between the magnetic field
and the magnetic
moment of the atom.
But, of course, we only get the
magnetic moment to the extent
that it comes from
orbital motion.
But in a semi-classical way,
I'm waving my hands now and say,
well, what is valid
for the coupling
to orbit to the magnetic moment
of the orbital angular momentum
also applies to the speed.
And I'm simply
adding the spin here.
And with that, I've
derived for you
the expression for the
interaction matrix element
called M1.
M1 is the magnetic
dipole transitions.
Let me just write it down here.
So this is nothing
else than u dot b.
Any questions?
Let me just summarize.
You may find it
sort of interesting,
when we discussed static
electric and static magnetic
fields.
For the static
electric field, we
had an electric field
times the dipole.
And we find this now as
a time independent term
which can drive transitions
for interactions with time
dependent electromagnetic
field, but we find it
in the dipole approximation.
The magnetic part,
u dot b, we find
when we go to the next order.
We find it as a
magnetic dipole term.
But there are more
terms, and I just
want you to illustrate
that and then
I'll stop with that
multiple expansion.
We had the second term,
the kr term, was this one.
But then we sort of
anti-symmetrized it
and symmetrized it.
The first one here, we could
relate to orbital angular
momentum and to the
magnetic moment.
And now I would want to
discuss the second term.
So that term uses a mixture
of position and momentum
operators.
But we know already how we can
get rid of momentum operators,
namely by expressing momentum
operators as commutators
with the Hamiltonian.
So this gives us the commutator
of z with H naught times x
plus z times the commutator
of x with H naught.
OK.
So we have two commutators.
Each of them has two terms.
That means a total
of four terms.
And if you write
them down, you see
that two are opposite
but equal and cancel.
So therefore we are left
with two terms, which
are minus H naught zx
plus zx times H naught.
So this term has now the
following contribution
to the coupling between
the levels A and B.
So we have this
coupling matrix element.
We have b factor mc Am.
OK.
So using the same approach
we used for the dipole matrix
element, the H naught can act on
the state A on the right side,
and can act on the state
B on the left hand side.
So this gives us simply
the energy difference.
And what is left is
now a matrix element
which only involves
position operators,
but it uses a product of 2.
And now, again, we express
the vector potential
by the electric field,
as we had done before.
And therefore we have now
expressed our coupling yes,
by an electric field.
And we assume that in the
near resonant approximation,
as we had used for
the dipole coupling,
that this is the
frequency omega.
OK.
So what we are
realizing is that we
have one part of the
interaction Hamiltonian
which couples levels
A and B, has--
we call it E2, this
electric quadrupole
because it involves elements
of the quadrupole tensor,
or products of coordinates
x, y, y, z, x, z.
And for this geometry, which
we assume with our plane wave,
it is z, x.
It couples to the
electric field.
And this is the p factor.
For a more general
geometry of plane waves
with different polarization
going in different directions,
we would have obtained different
products of coordinates.
So let me indicate that, that
what we have picked out here
is one specific component
of a tensor, which
is sort of the tensor form
by using the position vector
r twice.
So in this derivation,
we found when
we go beyond the
dipole approximation,
when we take the kr term
in leading order, that we
have two contributions.
One is M1, magnetic dipole.
The other one was
electric quadrupole.
We realized-- I tried to
keep of all the p factors--
that the electric quadrupole
matrix element is imaginary,
whereas the magnetic
dipole was u dot b.
There was no imaginary unit.
It's real.
That means that you will
never have any interference
effect between magnetic dipole
and electric quadrupole.
Or in other words,
when we have processes
like spontaneous
emission where we
take the square of
the matrix element,
the square of the
matrix element will
be the sum of the squares
of the matrix element
for magnetic dipole and
electric quadrupole transitions.
So let me summarize.
We have discussed
three different ways
how we can have coupling
matrix elements between two
states, electric
dipole, magnetic dipole,
electric quadrupole, E1, M1, E2.
The operator was the
electric dipole operator.
Here it was the operator of
the magnetic movement, which
is orbital angular momentum
and spin angular momentum.
And for the quadrupole, it
was the quadratic expression
in the spatial coordinates.
You can also ask
what is the parity?
The electric dipole
operator connects
states with opposite parity,
whereas both magnetic dipole
and electric quadrupole
connect states
even with the same parity.
Magnetic dipole and electric
quadrupole transition
are often called
forbidden transitions.
Well, you would say it's
a misnomer because they
are transitions, so they are
allowed, but they are weak.
But this is the language we use.
Weak transitions
are forbidden, which
simply means they don't appear.
They are forbidden
in leading order,
but when you go to higher
order, they are allowed.
You can, of course, say if
they were completely forbidden,
there would be no
need to discuss them.
But since they
are only forbidden
at a certain level,
then, of course,
it's interesting
to discuss them.
And a lot of narrow
transitions which
are relevant for atomic
clocks are highly forbidden
transitions.
The strength of them, which
usually scales with transitions
with the square of
the matrix element,
is on the order of 5
times 10 to the minus 5.
So those transitions
are four or five orders
of magnitude weaker Yeah than
an allowed E1 transition.
So that's what they are.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: When people talk about
highly forbidden transitions,
does this mean that's like
a optical transition, or how
do we distinguish it from
just regularly forbidden?
PROFESSOR: Actually I would
say forbidden transitions
are weaker by alpha
to the power n.
Here we have situations
where the matrix
element is just
smaller by alpha.
But, yes.
Sometimes, yes.
Some transitions are
highly forbidden.
For instance-- I
try to remember--
if you have hydrogen 1s and 2s.
Because of s states--
actually, you
are asking question about the
next chapter, namely about
selection rules.
Let me give it in words.
The s, if you
connect two s states,
they have both 0
angular momentum.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So you cannot have a
quadrupole operator connecting
the two.
It would violate
the triangle rule.
You cannot have angular momentum
of 0 and angular momentum of 2
and get angular momentum of 0.
So therefore you
have a transition
between two states
of the same parity.
There is no dipole operator.
There is no quadrupole operator.
So you soon run into a situation
where it's highly forbidden.
Sometimes you have the situation
that something is forbidden
in non-relativistic
physics, but they're
a relativistic term,
which makes it allowed.
Well, there's also
that relativistic terms
are fine-structure terms is
also an expansion alpha squared.
So the symmetry may
allow it, but only
in connection with
relativistic terms.
I'm not an expert on
forbidden transitions,
but usually you have transitions
which are multiply forbidden.
They are forbidden
by spacial symmetry.
For instance, in
the helium atom,
singular triplet are
forbidden by spin symmetry.
So if you have multiple
layers of being forbidden,
then you get extremely
weak transitions.
And one example, actually, are
the singular triplet transition
in helium, or the 1s to
2s transition in hydrogen.
They are not allowed
by simply going
to the next order in
a multiple expansion.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In ordinary
situations when
you do have to possibly do at
least even more [INAUDIBLE]
for the other transitions?
PROFESSOR: I'm not
an expert on that.
I'm not sure if there
is an atom which
has a relevant transition which
is a [INAUDIBLE] transition.
I've not heard about that.
At least relevant examples
which are the fundamental atoms,
helium and hydrogen.
For hydrogen, at the
2s to 1 transition,
the leading order
is the emission,
the simultaneous
emission of two photons.
So you have not
just one photon, you
have two photons which,
of course, requires
in the perturbation
expansion the immediate step.
We discuss two
photon transitions
at the end of this course.
So in that case, it's
not in higher order
in the single photon
multiple expansion,
it becomes a
multi-photon transition.
So this is one relevant case.
And for helium,
triplet to singlet,
this involves
relativistic physics.
Actually, I mentioned it in
the other class on helium.
I tried to look it up
and I want to show here,
you have to go to this
order to get a transition.
But when I tried to look
into the literature,
I couldn't find a clear answer.
Ultimately, it was
a relativistic term
in the fully
relativistic formulation
of the coupling of
electromagnetic fields
to the atom.
I'm not sure if you can put a
label on it and it would say,
this is this and
this order term.
It may actually
involve-- and we know
that this happens in the
[INAUDIBLE] creation--
that spin and spacial degrees
become treated together
in the [INAUDIBLE] creation, and
maybe it's one of those terms.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what's
the actual meaning
of interacting with
different Hamiltonians?
Like, you wrote square root
of Hamiltonians and then--
PROFESSOR: No.
I meant actually the square
of the matrix element.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Sorry.
PROFESSOR: If you have,
for instance-- actually
I will talk about it in
the next lecture when
we discuss Fermi's golden rule.
The transition strength
in Fermi's golden rule
is proportionate to the
square of the matrix element.
But now you would ask
the question, well,
could we have some
interference between the two
different processes?
And I wanted to point
out at this level
that we don't, because one
matrix element is imaginary,
the other one is real.
And if you take the complex
matrix element between two
states and calculate
the square, the square
of the complex matrix element
is the square of the real part
plus the square of
the imaginary part,
and there's no interference
trend between the two.
So in other words, if you have
an atom which has a weak decay
through M1 and a weak
decay through quadrupole,
the two parts cannot
destructively interfere,
because one is real,
one is imaginary.
They add up in quadrature,
That's what I wanted to say.
OK.
So these were examples of
higher order transitions.
And as the questions
have shown, this
leads us to a discussion
of selection rules.
Selection rules is nothing
else than a classification
of possible transitions
according to symmetry.
And it's a way of using well,
[INAUDIBLE] coefficients,
angular momentum coupling,
or using, you would say,
symmetry to figure out
if matrix elements are
non-vanishing or vanishing.
And I gave you
already one example,
and I want to formalize it now.
If you go between two s states
which have 0 angular momentum,
you cannot have an operator
which is a quadrupole operator
because-- and this is what
I want to tell you now--
the quadrupole operator is a
spherical tensor with two units
of angular momentum.
And this would forbid
the triangle rule.
This would forbid "conservation"
of angular momentum.
So that's what I want to
discuss now in the next chapter,
or at least get started
for the next five minutes
by discussing selection rules.
So the introduction
to selection rules
is that we have
forbidden transitions.
Forbidden transitions
are suppressed
because we are forced
to go to higher order,
and this is usually
higher order in alpha.
So forbidden transitions are
weaker by some power of alpha.
And that means they require
higher approximations.
And, of course, the
comparison is always
the dipole transition.
This is the dominant transition.
This is the industrial
strengths transition.
And from there on,
it can get weaker.
So if can get weaker
by multiple expansion.
We've just discussed that.
It can get weaker
because you have
to have a cascade of
dipole transitions.
This would be
multi-photon processes,
as we discuss later
in the course.
It can get weaker
because they are exactly
0 in a non-relativistic
approximation
and require
relativistic effects.
The example we have
encountered in this course
is the singlet to triplet
transition in helium.
Or there are transitions which
would not be allowed just
for the electron, but if we
invoke hyperfine interactions
with a nucleus, then
they become allowed.
So it's a rich subject, and I'm
not an expert and I cannot do
full justice to it.
But I want to at least give
you some general rules how
we discussed matrix elements.
So what is always a good
quantum number, what is always
a label for our atomic
states is angular momentum.
Because atoms [INAUDIBLE]
through space,
and there is
rotation in variance.
So we always categorize our
atoms with angular momentum
with the quantum numbers JM.
And we are asking,
are there transitions
between a state JM to a
state J prime M prime?
And all other
quantum numbers, we
can now summarize
with a label n.
And now we have an operator.
I gave you examples
for the operator.
The magnetic moment,
the electric dipole,
the quadrupole operator.
But in general, every
operator can be written,
can be expanded, in a
sum of spherical tensors.
So what is discussed
in the classification
of matrix elements.
Our matrix elements
involving components,
the operator are components
of a spherical tensor.
So T is a spherical
tensor of rank l.
And if you want a
simple definition
of what is a
spherical tensor, you
try to write an operator--
like the position operator
r-- you try to write
it as a sum of terms,
and each term transforms like
a spherical harmonic Ylm.
So in other words, we
can write every operator
as a sum of spherical tensors.
And a spherical tensor
is characterized
that it transforms
under rotations exactly
as the spherical harmonics Ylm.
so every operator is now a
sum of spherical tensors.
I don't want to get too much
into symmetry classification,
but the story is that you
know the Ylm functions are
compensator functions.
Every function can be expanded
and swell to harmonics.
And similarly, if
you have an operator,
you can decompose
it into objects
which transform under
rotation, and it's the Ylms.
So you have a part
which transforms
according to an object.
And Ylm is the classification
of wave functions
with angular momentum.
And so therefore each operator
may not have a specific angular
momentum, but can be written
as the sum of operators,
each of which has
the same symmetry,
the same transformation
properties,
as a state of angular momentum.
And I think I should
stop here, but let
me just give you
the final message.
So by doing that, by
separating the operator
into a sum of spherical tensors,
we are actually now back
in angular momentum.
If you have a matrix
element-- and just
think how you calculate it in
the Schrodinger representation.
You have a wave
function, operator,
and a wave function
we indicate go by.
So what you have is, you have
the product of the objects.
And now we can classify
them by angular momentum.
And this is what I will
show you in the next class,
is that ultimately the question
whether this matrix element is
0 or not will boil
down to the question
whether J prime and M
prime angular momentum
can be added to l and m.
And there is overlap with
angular momentum of JM.
So we are back to the rules
for adding angular momentum.
We get the triangle rule.
We get the [INAUDIBLE]
quote unquote [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
Enjoy the spring break,
and we meet on Monday
after the spring break.